well we're going to start on a very hot
topic
virtual dating uh-huh so refinery29 just
published their guide to a perfect
quarantine
zoom date and ross they have some tips
which i like because i'm like don't be
vague give me specificities
and all my friends who are single are
doing this so i want all these tips
all right so before the call take time
to set your frame
adjust your lighting so that you don't
have to worry about it like once the
call starts
fair do you have a ring light you know
those ones i don't do you
of course hello it's 20 21 you got to
get a ring light
no right okay also try to make it feel
like a real date
you can be specific it's a coffee date
or a wine date listen are we dry or are
we wet here you know what i'm saying
um you can use netflix party function to
watch a movie together oh i didn't know
that existed
yeah it's a whole thing there's so much
now that you can do if you want to date
online you people
they're trying to use it as an excuse
like oh it's so hard and it's pandemic
no more excuses everybody this it is
possible to date you remember i started
dating somebody at the beginning of the
pandemic that's right
and we would do this thing where we
would like i'd have like uber eats
delivered we'd have
dinner at the same time and if you're
just starting to date somebody brand new
this is great because say the date's
going really poorly
you can just be like oh oh oh oh
my wi-fi cut out i'm sorry and then
peace um
i haven't done that on zoom but i've
definitely done that on the phone
you faked it you faked the no signal
all right well we've got the perfect
menu for any zoom day
in today's food news
there it is with the num yum yum okay
what if i told you that you could have
wine and cheese and it would be good for
you
uh my butt would say no way
uh correction they would say no you did
but
but it's true in fact martha stewart
living reports that wine and cheese can
actually improve
your brain health yep a scientific study
conducted over 10 years showed that it
has real benefits for cognitive function
which if you ask me sounds like pretty
gouda news
yeah it does so i just decided now every
time i go to happy hour i'm just going
to say i'm taking my meds
yeah crying i bet the people in that
study over 10 years are happy because
they're not pretending that they can
deprive themselves of everything
and still find joy because you can't
well they're probably hot because
they're a little tipsy
okay well check this out ross tick tock
is full of treasures
it really is totally i love this latest
design tip okay
people are making their homes extra cozy
with these
ge stained glass light bulbs and they're
each
hand painted to lend a soothing
colorful look to the room i really
am into this what do you think well i
hate overhead lighting i hate a room
that's too bright at night it's got to
feel dim
and intimate this is a no-brainer i've
never had this or seen this and i'm
obsessed oh i just had a bright idea
my mom's father um shani he was a
stained glass maker also so
yeah he this really reminds me of him
[Music]